are we going back to the school
scariest school i've ever been to
okay so this is where we left off i'm
gonna have to remember
so if i die not my fault
i'm getting i'm getting back to
remembering
[Music]
not my fault as i just said
[Music]
how do i run again okay let's
controls crouch and slide
grab square oh my god my flashlight
remote i get a remote later on
okay
oh my god oh we are one lucky duck
oh [ __ ]
ah pick it back up
that's not fair her animation was stuck
behind the bucket
okay let's let's not go that fast
although i thought we did pretty
good
it's gonna be another one
yes
music hasn't stopped which means we're
not safe
[Music]
all right all right smarty pants how do
i run with the legs
oh yeah i see
[Music]
come on me oh god
no
excuse me
thanks for following um all right
i read that as small poop but it's
[Music]
oh for smooth sake again get him
where's also aiming this game
well i'm gonna maybe just keep moving as
she comes towards me so i'm a bit
further away from him
there you go
oh [ __ ] sake
it's actually stupid that was easier
though
all right come on
i don't know what that was about
come on
[Music]
i don't like this
yeah it's the same thing i always say
about the depth of this game
okay come on there you go
all right are you gonna do your little
animation there you go
just need to trust that they're always
gonna stop before the attack
and that's my cue to aim he's hiding
from me
[Music]
this fit is hard
[Music]
animation
that was my fault i timed it wrong
[Music]
so i woke up to this one
i don't trust it oh thank god for the
depth
i thought it was i thought i was in the
door frame then but i wasn't
oh crap wait it's a friend
[Music]
no you [ __ ] me i hit right next to
him
oh thank god look at his little bum bum
i didn't see him wagging his bum like
that did you see
i hit the [ __ ] party
thank you
[Music]
i mean i'm surprised there aren't a few
broken bones
[Music]
we get to hold hands again best part of
the game
oh i missed this human interaction
look guys are you jealous
well that's one club toilet we can't go
for a toilet here
come on then let's go
thanks for following veneer veneers
i think so
oh it doesn't look good it looks like it
might break
turn around we're gonna live on this
beam for now
no okay never mind
oh god i don't trust okay
it's a grand piano
no freaking way how do i have this
strength
must be a mechanism doing most of the
heavy lifting
because there's no way this little kid
can do that
oh jesus stay away from that little one
what are you doing
[Music]
any secrets around here
[Music]
oh when i talk because i've got a buck
up my head it's all echoey
are we going down
[Music]
look we've got to do it together okay
go now
[Music]
okay hello i see you
bish
what what do you want
oh you're gonna give me a boost wait but
what if there's something good around
here that i
haven't seen
okay if we gotta find a key
come on
um what's that a frog
are you probing a frog with a key that's
disgusting how am i gonna
kill that all right get ready for me to
die again
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
they're actually so scary
oh i missed
i got it
all right let's go now
[Music]
yay sorry froggy
[Music]
do you guys want me to turn um my mic
down just in case i'm
too loud when i do scream i mean
it's inevitable really isn't it
someone plays the piano better than me
obviously showing off
[Music]
yes you hold him oh wow
okay never mind how did you do that
she did that hold on
wait are you gonna be something
something evil
are you am i holding hands with the
with the devil
holding hands with the devil
oh
[Music]
wait
[Music]
i love the fact that you can't see in
front of you it makes it just
so much scarier
i want a flashlight it's getting louder
i don't know anyone like it's so loud
[Music]
am i missing things i haven't found
anything cool and ages
[Music]
oh i think that's where i'm supposed to
[Music]
go
[Music]
okay let's see what's in there then
up to the bird poop
am i leaving you again
come on you got this maybe not
i need you up here please
[Music]
the music is ramping up that means
something scary is a foot
i just jumped right down there didn't i
[Music]
i mean she can play she's good at that
[Music]
[Music]
can i not get up on the beam i don't
wanna i don't wanna have to like
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
am i gonna do this
[Music]
do i have to push that somewhere
do i have to push this
[Music]
no okay
bye matas
[Music]
do i have to push that thing to get back
up
let's have a look
[Music]
no hopefully we can just scale the books
[Music]
she's doing it for longer
[Music]
[ __ ] oh no i have to
[Music]
i have to do this i have to push it oh
crap
[Music]
[Music]
i don't want to play
it's too much i'm so close
and it's so squeaky
[Music]
yes
[Music]
don't get this wrong
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
go
i hate it
[Laughter]
is that the last we see of her i really
hope so
oh my gosh that was so creepy
oh bless you uk cold come on
[Music]
oh my god it looks so scary
[Laughter]
that was a performance right damn
yeah i got scared
that was just intense
okay come on we got this
let's do this
oh my god
they got some balls
[Music]
wow that's really pretty the way they've
got
the rain coming down the buildings
it's like it's quite cartoonistic really
oh hello he's a weird man
he's invisible only as clowns as you can
see
let's
i just saw someone say spoilers so i'm
not gonna look at the chat
oh i know i'm sincere wait i don't go up
there
there's attention behind it
can i move that rock out the way
okay i guess i'll just have to jump
through it
what
how
somehow
me
how am i confused about this
kind of you guys think i'll figure it
out we'll see
do you think he doesn't just balance on
the side but he doesn't
i don't think i am smart guys i don't
know what the hell i'm doing
can't seem to do anything with this tv
can't move can't find the breeze
can't do this anywhere else
oh my god yes
[Music]
like 10 minutes
[Music]
come on
oh it's gonna be on my head and my
little hat
oh i was hoping it would like you know
splatter off my helmet or something
just goes through it
oh i was hoping it would be a hat
because that would be so cute
with the hat little paper hat
is there a stream i can put this thing
because that would be really
i don't know what the weather would be
that'd be very um
just pleasing please give me a stream
game for me to put the
boat in oh come on oh fine i'll give it
to
it
oh no don't chuck it here
there you go
what's this what is that
it's her from the first game
oh well she is a little bit evil then
isn't she
look at you you're so cute and i can
hold your hand now
there you go thank you
bouncy bouncy bouncy
bouncy bouncy
look at how many uh what those polyps i
can do look
i'm so strong my big muscles
it's so strong
is this another hat from my head that's
too big
i do want another hat though i've
ordered this one
i could change it though so we're
matching
now we're both little sailors little
yellow sailors
anything up here
i want to go to the bell
oh excuse me
the shoes in the bin this game loves
shoes
every time
give me your hand please thank you
hmm this one's too high up
for us to get thank you
hat too big my head
i love that fall damage just isn't a
thing what's this big package
exciting
hello
so now that i'm like playing this game
this has got to be kind of a prequel to
the first game
so where did he go what happened to him
for us what happened to this guy
any secrets around this big place
haven't found any secrets in a while
i can't really see much of anything to
be honest
okay
okay so now we're in a different place
which means we're gonna come across
something
different
which is always fun let's break stuff
not strong enough
not even after on my pull-ups one
what's in those jaws
are we in where the hell are we
are we in a jail cell are we
in a hospital
someone in a wheelchair so maybe a
hospital
[Music]
good night maria thank you for coming
oh we can i go through here
[Music]
oh that was close
oh this is so cool
oh no man
[Music]
okay let's climb up
just don't let go grab when you do
things like that oh no
i hate stuff like this too
oh grab yeah
oh god i don't like all this
grab oh god
at least it's kind of it's it's not too
wide the options i can't really go too
wide with it
it's all the same
heal up button
rage against the system
oh i really wish these things like the
toilet walls would just open up and then
flourish
but no i'm asking too much
oh can we take this one out and put it
in there
oh
she's heavy
what's that am i dead was that supposed
to
i was supposed to have i was trying to
hold on to the rope
come on take out this guy
come on take it out
hey chasey
okay so i have to go down there
maybe i should try the rope again i only
have a few seconds until
that's weird
the game just went black and pulls
itself okay
oh god come on
i don't think you can grab the rope
there's the vent on the other side but i
think that's too high why is it so
difficult for him to like grab that
i'm not smart
i wish i could just
tell her to stay up here while i figure
it out
thanks for following grinch 1400
there you go
i do what i do what
[Music]
i hate this headache
i have a torch
oh creepy
oh nice good
[Music]
i can control it better
any hats though
any hat for me
hat
thanks for coming rainier sex though
every flashlight in every horror game is
not reliable
okay so the blood trails are taking us
all the way to the right but then there
are oh god i don't know where to go
there's a leg
wait can i still hold your hand
yay ah but you're holding my flashlight
hand that's annoying
wait can i wear that leg as a hat
no that's stupid
uh i think we are correct though that
this is a hospital yes
i do believe so
whenever you jump and climb things it
goes dark so
if we have to do any platforming like
this it's not gonna be easy
i'm guessing that's or maybe there'll be
a door here that's like locks or
something
oh yeah
papatay
cup of tea
[Music]
jerking these what these are open can i
grab this one
that's open on the floor oh
you can't grab that
darn it
sure nikki you can tell me when a hat is
closed i'm not gonna turn down a free
hat hint
weird noises coming from that room
or soda soda
hold up can i grab this
no the tickets i want the tickets
no okay
thanks for following john ceela
john cena
[Music]
sorry
[Music]
oh hell yeah nikki says this level has a
whole hat
it's creepy
what did i have to do here
there we go
[Music]
go go go you can reach the door what is
this
door all about
i must get closer each time and then by
the end up we'll get to the door
[Music]
so
yeah that was cool that was very
cinematic
can i pick up this i want to be hook i
want to be
her captain hook
oh this
oh there's some faces to explore where
do i get first let's go upstairs
i'm sure there'll be nothing up here but
okay so we got to explore we've got to
get two
uh energy things that we can use
the elevator
oh i'm going for this door
hmm okay
ah denise told you to check my stream
that's really nice
of her that's sweet oh if anyone here is
a youtuber
or a streamer or a podcaster check out
denise takes
um she's made some audio for
youtubers and podcasters streamers to
to use on their streams and they don't
have to worry about copyright so
check it out
uh it's spelt d-e-n-i-s-e
takes t a k b s
there's a teddy bear with a key in it
of course why wouldn't that oh
can i see my insides if uh if you do the
thing
yes yes you knew what i wanted
it's me hello
[Music]
look at this we're so tiny we're so cute
hello
that's so cute so adorable hello
again hello hello
hold my hand
oh this must be the bunny
oh wait no the butt the teddy bear's up
there it's
it's legs are wobbling but this one is
freaking creepy no
it's so scary oh she's picked her
favorite toy already
who's this oh get that
get that box out of there i wanted to
put this
this teddy bear on the chair obviously
needs a chair
or maybe we can put this teddy bear on
here then
no get up there
no
put it up there that'll do
what about you
i think we just have to x-ray all of
them i really do feel like it's gonna be
that one with the wobbly feet though
maybe you have something secret in you
though let's have a look
i mean she likes a little duck toy but
i love how they flop around in the hand
all right
exo please assistant
get the x-ray go on
fine i have to do everything around here
i could just get them all and x-ray them
all at the same time
look if you got the big one then we
could be done with this a lot quicker
put that duck down there's nothing
inside the duck
fine do what you want
oh my gosh
out my way all right let's just check
out these guys
whenever i put one down the other one
gets thrown out the way oh this is just
not working
okay there we go
hey there it is
in that one
hey is this something actually in your
duck
there's it's this one that we need to
rip open
so i'll leave this one here just for
reference but let's you can hear the key
inside of it
but let's just get this one anyway
because i like this game
it's fun
kids are drawing men in black on the
walls
[Music]
where's your duck on oh there it is
okay
um what do we have then to stab open
this uh
this uh bear
do we stab her open with the duck
why were you holding on to this for so
long
is this important
thank you
no what
she's a duck
anything sharp in here know it's a kid's
playroom but i mean i wouldn't really
put it past this place
there's a really some really creepy
dolls this one its whole head is just
a big gaping mouth
oh what have you got now oh you're the
cutest
oh she's forming little attachments with
toys it's adorable
what's this then oh
i found a new hat
yeah here oh
i can be a disgusting teddy bear
oh my god that's revolting i love it
but there's nothing sharp in here look
at me go
i look uh terrifying
i like i like that that they've thought
about um changing
the voice for him when he's wearing the
different hats i wonder what it sounds
like
with the ball
oh it sounds the same so it's just it's
just really
the differences in the tin can
see
what about in the paper
yeah that's a lot clearer oh this is
sound the same as just a normal hat yeah
it does
yeah cool small things
i like that
scissors these were being hidden can i
pick these up
i found some scissors
no i don't want the i want the scissors
on the floor
oh i don't think they'd be sharp enough
really though
no i can't pick them up
somehow that door got broken
i feel like i did a mistake here uh
i feel like i should have brought the
bear down here
let's just
oh okay
hopefully this is
[Music]
that's terrifying
why did she decide to bring those so
scary
i love that because that's quite random
like
if we hadn't gone back twice she
wouldn't have picked that up and that
wouldn't have happened
that was scary that was
emergent horror
it was like it's the term i tried to
coin in uni
it's like the horror that designers can
even design for
all right in you go
not me oh
this is when she just pulls it
oh gosh oh i'm sad there aren't any
secrets in here though
apart from my hand okay bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
anything else around this spooky more
hey kyla reed and propunene
liquor
oh we don't need to go here where are we
going let's focus
we have a key
i don't like i'm just being mean i don't
look like i'm being
nice i'm just dragging her around
everywhere
sorry i'll let you go
prosthetic limbs
prosthetic limbs everywhere
can we go up
oh why did that scare me what
i knew there'd be something up here
oh my gosh i have a flashlight i totally
forgot sorry
shiny in your face
it looks like you can break through
there
you look so nice in your shirt
oh and it's sad because it's
oh yeah good good shout is there
anything else around
that no okay okay oh sorry oh sorry you
need to do that again
i'm messed up
so this isn't really a hospital this is
like some sort of prosthetic limb
clinic or something i don't know
oh what do i think the next boss will
look like
that's a good question i mean it's got
to be something to do with
doctors um
i would say prosthetic limbs obviously
but i don't know
because maybe it's the you know like a
mad
doctor thing that's like making all of
the prosthetic limbs but
oh my god where am i going where am i
going
okay it's definitely a prosthetic lip
monster
is it just a bloody hand
the thing chasing me
this is the second hand shop jesus
oh yeah dodge like a [ __ ] pro
[Music]
go go go
it's a facehugger it's like an alien
okay i don't think i need my um what
come on come on come on come on after me
oh my god
i don't know what it is
no i don't i don't know i don't know i
don't know where to go i don't know
where it's gonna go
can i use this
get the hand caught in it
up up [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i'm lucky it didn't jump on the table
i need this
do i go left or do i go back
oh god
here what is it's thing from the addams
family
how am i gonna do this
we're both just jumping around the place
oh i can [ __ ] kill it
right gotcha i'm on your wavelength now
wait there let's get it away
come on
yes i got his little fingers
get your
that's just gonna be what's haunting me
oh god
i think i did quite quite get that
considering i didn't know
what to do for a little while i'm
surprised i didn't die
oh maybe i'll just pull this box then
all right
i was chucking this one around i'm
surprised i didn't break it
can i really not pull it anymore why not
there we go
there you go
what are you doing uh
hello
what are you doing
i mean to be fair i'm also killing them
but are you assembling it
because that's a little bit weird i'm
judging you
with my bare eyes
to know you can take out uh look after
yourself though
okay let's use this to open that door
[Music]
oh sweet corn hell yeah
you know what corn the cob is one of
those things it's very annoying
because it tastes really nice but i hate
that it gets stuck in your teeth
and then you eat it and then for ages
afterwards you're like
because you just got loads of tiny
little clear bits stuck in your teeth
and then you just kind of wish you
didn't really eat it
fun facts
another electricity thing
oh
is this um more of like a mental asylum
or something then like a mental hospital
an old-fashioned one it would be fitting
i don't trust that woman
but god oh god
what am i doing
does she not like love
oh god no one of these
i hate stuff like this it's so spooky
it moves so fast i hate it
oh my poor little bear herself can't
take it
oh my gosh
it's quite comedic though just seeing
this little bear just like oh no if
oh
[Music]
so many scary things
i trust you don't trust you don't trust
you i don't trust you
don't trust anyone
[Music]
oh gosh
oh god oh god i still like give me a
minute
nice answer
no it's gonna be you
oh this is horrible you're just waiting
for the next one
see this this is horror right here
the anticipation oh god
one of them is gonna don't
don't ah this kind of gave
is giving me like bioshock vibes because
bioshock used to do this to the player
very well
and it's quite hard to do it actually in
a first person game
that bioshock was really good at just
like
surprising you with little things that
you did not expect
[Music]
i think i'm gonna have to quit i can't
play this is too late no i can't play i
can't
i can't play this i've gotta quit it's
too late
this is too scary i can't do it oh i'll
try one more time
i just
i feel bad i don't want to like scream
what's so loud it's so late but like i
have freaking out
there's too many of them maybe should i
just run like i can't
where am i going
got you got you i see you
i see all of you i see you i don't know
where i'm going though
this is bad
oh why did i go this way i don't think i
was supposed to go this way
oh my god oh my god oh my god
little little
[Music]
wait i think he was floating in the air
was he oh back here again
okay i know where i'm going i'm not
scared anymore
let's let's back out i was literally
about to back out
i was getting scared
i know i know you i know you're alive
okay which one comes alive here i forgot
oh yeah the one that's floating
[Music]
are you floating your peg leg is you're
floating he is floating right i'm not
just
seeing this it's floating
no wonder you can move floating sir
[Laughter]
[Music]
hmm
don't you dare come any closer
come on
oh god hey do things like this
oh god
without a doubt hands down one of the
scariest games i've played in a long
time
i'll play a lot of scary games
oh thank you so much profunelli
liquor this is terrifying but keep it
going thank you for the support
because i did nearly just back out i got
too scared i wasn't
expecting it's horrible where am i going
i've got to be going this way surely
oh oh the obvious open vent
did they miss something though do they
miss like a hat or something
curlery jump
oh dear
cheese yum
[Music]
i guess i can crawl through these holes
oh no i'm small but i'm not that small
i was just about to like comment on how
i'm scared he looked in his cute little
little uh bear hat and then the the arms
just like came out in front of me
no i made it i thought i
saw it it snapped into its hand that's
not fair
i keep saying really inappropriate
things i've got to stop
[Music]
go
that way
can i turn on the light please
hallelujah
so i probably haven't had a wash in a
while scrubby dub dub
so pat
secrets
hello that's fine let me just have a
little look around
is that like oh oh i see
[Music]
i should probably go through here right
his secrets secrets
i hope this isn't the way i'm supposed
to go because i i want to explore
everywhere
i don't know which way is the right way
someone
someone tell me in the chat i don't want
to progress i want to
you know i mean i don't want to not be
able to i'm just going to check the
other room
unless maybe that's my way back
spooky no that is the way i'm supposed
to go anyway never mind
i want to get in the bath
he's hogging all the rooms
any good stuff any good stuff for me
thanks for following sub p x
okay let's go back here
oh this is a flies
oh right
[Music]
what is that
[Music]
i mean i know it's a person but i mean
what's the yellow stuff
guts
[Music]
some weird intestine a snake
for sure
oh this wasn't where i was supposed to
go sequence
[Music]
another shoe on the floor
okay then well nice to see you sir
i guess i'll i'll leave
oh apparently sub px been watching for
ages and they don't know why they've
only just subbed well
thank you anyway i appreciate it
hopefully i can still keep making some
really like
pro gamer streams for you then you guys
have a lot to learn from me
i say when i am actually stuck right now
maybe i can push the guy in the
i wheelchair know what's expected to
happen then
maybe i can let's push you
excuse me he's too scared to touch it oh
unless oh unless
i have to let the guy in the wheelchair
out of the wheelchair by turning off the
light
i think
hello
please get up out of the world
i knew it as well
put a slight a little stare down right
now
i'm backing up backing up back it up who
is old enough to remember that song
is my daddy taught me good
back in the hell out of there and i'm
like oh my god
oh my god oh my god i'm backing up
backing up back and i'm backing up
cause my daddy taught me good
they have time these things like so so
so wow they have timed it
so good there's so many moments where i
feel like i've just made it
ah well done props
they've done so well
oh god get me out of here
no more no more i don't want them
[Music]
matt pitt he's scaring me
is it you
but thank you
there's so many
i just have to make it through i really
hate
like stopping the game on uh
on a point like this come on we've gotta
just do it
another way
the problem is when you run you that you
can't like
use the so you use the um the right
analog stick to direct where your
flashlight is going and you can't really
do that while you're running so you're
like
it's either where i run or i use my
flashlight like which which one
which one
this freaking guy always gets me
maybe i'm gonna have to not run and just
try and like actually
just turn around with my flashlights
this guy this [ __ ] guy oh my god all
of them
oh so many
i really don't want to stop the game
here though
come here
what's that wolf game
i see you i see you i
see you i see you oh i
see you and i see you and i see
you and i see you and i see you
and it's [ __ ] there's so many of you
i see you all
i see you and i see you and i see
you and i see you
okay
i made it to the room yeah
okay hello
[Music]
it's okay i'm safe don't worry about me
electro compulsive therapy
you guys want a [ __ ] ball
get out of here i just want to achieve
my stuff
then we're playing catch oh
this game is so good
it's like playing a game with squash but
uh
wow they didn't catch it
touch it throw it back to me i got it
i'm ready
the cutest
anyway
so they used to get people to look at a
picture
of a black swirl and then just
lap
yes now we've got another one
i got it can i pass it to you through
here no
uh can i just chuck it in there
[Music]
my god oh i missed you hug grab my hand
oh my god i need an emotional support
right now
it's so scary
[Music]
i hope we don't come across any more of
those things but i know it probably will
it's so scary
okay and that is where we shall end it
i'm quite i'm quite proud i'm proud of
that though
that without a doubt this
playthrough from the ladies head like
chasing us through the vents
to these freaking terrifying
mannequins this has been
yeah an experience i'm looking forward
to playing the game but i'm not gonna
play anymore tonight because i
probably won't sleep um i'm at a very
heightened state of anxiety right now
that's for sure
ah emotional support is for weaklings
all right
oh my bulldog
i am absolutely loving this game though
like honestly
i know i said it last time but so many
tiny things
this game is just such such a good mix
of
just cute things but also terrifying
things and then
things that make you laugh and you've
got you know your little emotional
support here a little
hand holding and then just tiny things
like being terrified
that these mannequins have just chased
me into a room
and then there's a ball and they're like
i wonder
what the players want to do with the
ball they probably want to chuck it at
the hands
oh let's just get the hands to play
fetch with them then
a weird idea especially to like include
in a horror game because i can see a lot
of
um people being like well no that
wouldn't really fit
the theme of horror you the the player
must be scared
that's not the point they don't have to
be scared all the time they need to have
these
these points in between where because
then it's not fun
if you're scared all the time it's not
actually fun you have to have
moments of lulls or moments of like
character development or
connection or just something fun and
also it
it puts you into a sense of like false
false hope i guess like false safety um
so you're never quite sure you're always
kind of on your toes
but you're not constantly always anxious
because that also
isn't fun if i had to do that little
stretch
for like half an hour maybe i did do
that for half an hour
but if i had to do that type of you know
dark room
multiple things chasing after me for an
elongated amount of time
and i just managed to get past them and
then i got to another room and there was
something else straight away that i had
to hide from that just wouldn't be fun
and that is outlast too
but um ah yeah i'm really enjoying this
i can't wait to play
again next week